mais c'est miraculeux en fait que que
les gens viennent quand même dans les
salles de cinéma non qui se déplacent
parce que la tentation la tentation
d'être soi même une fiction avec les
réseaux sociaux avec tout ce qui vous
soutient être soi-même et de soi même un
film est là est un lac et follow la
tentation de pu regarder de plus
concentré une minute trente c'est
beaucoup une vie série à 1h30 c'est quoi
être une fiction face à une autre
fiction un des petits fils des petits
morceaux de films nous mêmes
je suis un film alors de quel côté de
l'écran et le film au festival de cannes
parfois la scène est tellement
spectaculaire que le film lui-même
s'arrêtent pour regarder c'est inouï
d'être là et pourtant ça existe encore
chan pourrait bien c'est existe la salle
de cinéma ce besoin d'être ensemble
parce que le cinéma ça n'est pas juste
des images des images meilleurs que
d'autres
les images pure contre l'impur ça n'est
pas juste le grand écran contre le petit
le mais les yeux plutôt que les baisser
le cinéma le cinéma c'est la salle de
cinéma théâtre ensemble pour à fait vrai
sortir de chez soi
ce miracle là plutôt que de rester là à
manger des pizzas au regard de netflix
ou bien regarder sa pizza ou bien je
regardais en train de regarder sa pizza
le cinéma c'est ça c'est le collectif
c'est le groupe c la chaleur humaine ne
rentrez pas chez vous ce soir
bienvenue à la 72e cérémonie au 62e
festival de cannes tout simplement